then Wyatt hello hi Leslie good to see
you wow you really burning up can I get
some money for the cab that I took over
here please sure how much I'm not sure I
looked at the meter and it had Egyptian
hieroglyphics on it
do you know the exchange rate so should
we do this oh boy hold on be careful
what the floor and the wall just
switched okay walk very carefully
you know I find it a little insulting
that you don't trust me to handle this
I don't trust you okay it's this Harvest
Festival is my project it's my career on
the line and I just need to make sure
that I've done everything I can to make
it work okay it's show time
good evening everyone I'm Leslie monster
and this is Nightline I think I should
drive you the hospital was I wearing a
tiara when I came in here because if you
happen upon it well you have lady penny
face retrieve it and send it post hence
Tammy Tammy Ronnie what's going on
welcome to the Battle Royale
right here right now operation soaring
Falcon is in its final stages it's time
to settle this an old-fashioned prairie
drink God what's in that jug it smells
like jet fuel that's Swanson family mash
liqueur made from the finest corn ever
grown on American soil it's only legal
use is to strip varnish off of
speedboats if you whinnies all yours
and if I win I bring him back to the
farm for good what that wasn't the deal
port I'm thirsty pour me one too then
let me in here I'm gonna join you and if
I win Ron stays here with us Leslie no
don't drink that we use it to burn warts
off of the Mules poison oh I made a
mistake
I made a mistake
Edna this watered-down baby formula
not even close not even close
Marvin clones Glenn Close Leslie you
don't have to do this go to bed Jimmy
Wow I can't feel my face my face is numb
yeah mom you're going back to the farm
and you hmm
you're going back to hell fine I got
what I came for anyway
I found your underground safe I stole
half your gold that's decoy gold you
think I'd leave my gold in a locked safe
buried underground where anyone could
find it you don't know me at all yes I
do I knew you the minute you were born I
intend to be there the minute you die
your family's weird hate it here this
place is evil I think these are the only
two films that say sweetums on the label
yeah well let's take them both with my
friend something interesting here just
stick them under my shirt I'll just walk
out they have sensors just check them
out it's free hey Marcy
Leslie aren't they finally teaching you
parks people how to read oh I guess not
tamam fee you're pretty cocky for
someone whose job is obsolete because of
the Internet
[Laughter]
hmm you seem to have a $40 late fee on a
book called mysteries of the female
orgasm no I don't yeah you do
I just want to check one last time that
you're okay about this date with mark oh
my god I'm so fine with it and seriously
it's so fine as long as you and I are
cool you know my code hos before Bros
uterus is before do Teresa got it
ovaries before ovaries hmm midships food
coffee look I know you're saying you're
okay with it but I've been in this
position before and I had a friend who
dated an ex and I said I was okay but I
wasn't actually it was kind of weird but
the thing is mark isn't my ex you know
we slept together six years ago anyway
I'm over it or am i I'm just kidding hey
Leslie what are you doing here why are
you sleeping I just I thought maybe
you'd want to talk more about all the
crazy stuff going on I do I really do
Thanks yeah I'm just gonna tell you I'm
a little tired okay so I may have parked
on your front lawn oh you did I did hmm
Leslie and I had an amazing talk it was
so great of her to come over here even
though she was exhausted beyond belief
anyway after we talked she fell asleep
on my couch and she's been asleep for 22
hours it's amazing what she slept
through at one point I thought she was
up : hey hey but then she went right
back to sleep I've been monitoring her
vital signs she's totally fine I love
her so much but I think I'm gonna draw a
mustache on her face although I have not
worked with you professionally as a
private citizen I have personally
patronized each and every one of your
establishments I've never seen you buy a
salad it's a salad it's because I don't
hate myself Tanya I'm sorry I know I
should be chasing your vote but I stand
behind my decision to avoid salad and
other
disgusting things and I think I have a
lot of support in the community for that
look we are gonna be here for ten hours
we could either talk about our issues
and work through our problems or we can
just sit here doing nothing
I choose sit here come on Ron why don't
we just shoot her
Ron sit here I bet I can make you talk
I'll take that bet at any odds for any
amount of money over any length of time
stretching from now into infinity talk
to me talk to me talk to me okay one
word and this is over I think wood is
stupid so does everybody else
you guys Ron loves plastic Last Chance
Ron you want to talk huh aha
jackpot what this is Ron this is a mix I
made for the summer parks BBQ 2007 I
asked everyone in the parks department
to choose one song you chose buddy by
Willie Nelson a fact I remember because
my mind is a steel trap of friendship
nuggets but I am NOT going to play your
choice I'm gonna play Jerry's choice
[Music]
that's right and I'm gonna sing along
and I'm gonna maintain eye contact the
whole time Harry Truman was the guy
America Red China all the countries
other people everyone is fun
Joe Montaigne emic Ellen I have to buy
new toaster this is awesome you're so
stupid jumping up and down Oh Pete Marra
won hear it again or you want to talk no
okay okay here's the situation your
parents went away on a week's vacation
they left the keys to the brand-new
Porsche okay mine well of course not
I'll just take it for a little spin and
maybe show it off to couple the friends
I'll just cruise around the neighborhood
I shouldn't yeah of course I should pay
attention here's the thick of the plot
pulled up to the corner at the end of my
block that's when I saw this beautiful
girly girl walk and I picked up my car
phone to perpetrate like I was talking
sunroof was open the music was high and
that girl's hand was steadily moving up
my thought she had opened up three
buttons on a shirt so far I guess that's
why I didn't notice that police car I
can't believe it I made a mistake my
parents are the same no matter time nor
place so to all you kids all across the
land no need to argue parents just don't
understand something I know so what's up
someone is on fire and Rams at park they
need you to get down there right away oh
my god there's this everybody and to the
cab Tom to the trunk Jerry's on the roof
all right we're to first you Mouse but
[Laughter]
you